you should know that Cheryl I think can
I describe you a little bit or about
your experience with Mad TV yeah what do
you mean what do you mean by that Robert
what do you think about that I don't
like your tone for members of your
audience that don't understand why
Cheryl and I would be on this your show
together we're married yes yes that's
true they are married yeah yeah they're
married you have children
seven kids yes yeah and Larry David
introduced them I know that yeah right
yeah but not but not in a way that was
like well you guys should get together
yeah it wasn't like a blind day no it's
just like here you guys but when you
first met did you want to smash or no no
whoa
whoa I think seven years later when we
were both getting divorced and it was on
a um it was on a ski uh
event I put on every year for my for my
uh for my organization water keeper
which is a big
uh water protection group
boats on 350 but the water's fine order
the water is good that's I because I
don't want to worry oh from polluters my
bad okay oh yeah environment stuff yes
environmental okay exactly
people fish in these Waters Bobby these
ones they drink that's if they were like
you know being destroyed I don't know
anyway I thought there's a war on it I
thought there was a war on water all of
a sudden but oh yeah go ahead so you're
on a ski thing so we it was a pro
celebrity ski event
who's there who's there
name drop uh well Larry David for one
that's a big one uh the previous move
was involved at some point Marsha
gayhearted JB he's black right yeah he
is yeah I do too yeah
um but there were lots of people we had
a lot of uh
we got a good turnout good I could go
through no but don't Elizabeth it would
sound like a name dropping
[Laughter]
sorry that was a dumb question so you're
at the ski resort you guys see each
other
they didn't want to ski
you didn't want to stop me and Larry no
we weren't gonna ski we were just gonna
go and say hi and Bobby was like the
next thing I know
he we're being fitted for skis
for I spent two summers living together
and
we were going on we went on our
vacations together oh family is dead
very sweet oh and our kids attended the
um uh Hebrew
summer camp together my daughter was
best friends with Larry's two daughters
and uh
oh
um yeah so he had just started
curb and he brought Cheryl with him to
the ski event and they didn't intend to
ski but they ended up skiing yes that
was at the very beginning so then I
didn't even I didn't really know him for
years I know but when you first met him
did you think he was attractive
I thought you know what he wasn't really
my vibe
in your face oh man
holy man you gotta live with that what
hello I just remember
surprise surprise I remember him wearing
a pleated khakis and I was like whoa
whoa that's not my vibe I know what's
Vibe that's no one's five I'm out of
those immediately
that sounds weird because you look great
now what you're wearing now I love you
know yeah yeah yeah
this was my uniform
you know blue jeans before I got sober
okay it was part of my like you know
you know changing the spiritual
realignment when I came in and I
switched to khakis but then she she
broke your spiritual life
it was like a slow burn then well I
didn't even I never saw
I never really thought about him no
offense
um for a year
our lives were dusted in different
places and then at some point like years
and years later I was going through a
divorce he was going through a divorce
and so I saw him I was like oh hey oh
hey how's it going and then she came to
another event another Escape event yeah
seven years later and then there was
like a little connection like oh oh hi
I went to Larry I knew what I wanted
when I wanted to date her when I could
tell the how attracted she was to me
she was in heat
I could tell that your senses okay
I went to because I know Larry has a lot
of rules about that kind of stuff since
she was his television wife
that he wouldn't that it would be
important that I ask his permission so
yeah it's something that that sounds
great yeah yeah yeah so then so then I
went to the Carl uh hotel at 11 o'clock
at night and had a meeting with them
is that real yeah wow
and I said you know I said I I want I
want you to know that I'm
uh attracted to Cheryl what would you
think if I was dating her
and what do you say he shocked me and I
know this isn't what he was thinking I
know now that this is not what he was
thinking because he later reenacted this
in the show and more Ted Danson kind of
oh right
and then it came out what he was really
thinking oh in the show it was coming
wow
no you cannot date
he acted very excited and happy and he
he said some things about Cheryl that I
now know to be true and that I suspected
then which he said
he said that she was the uh the most
perfect human being that he'd ever met
Heavens
she was the she was she was beloved in
her industry that she she was the only
person in the industry
who didn't have a single enemy those uh
you know that's true those are true
quotes that he told me and that should
be widely known yeah because I have so
many I don't know how so many I really
do yeah I beat with everyone yeah I have
wars constantly through three years or
is it just you against them speak it's
them
they're not what they're going to wear
if I'm driving this way I see them on a
billboard there's a war yeah yeah yeah
how dare they get more successful